-My next guest is one of the
biggest models on the planet,
and she just launched
a brand-new YouTube channel
that you can check out
starting today.
Here's our pal Hailey Bieber.
Hailey! Oh!
-It is so good to see.
-Hi!
-You were on here last year,
probably exact right
before the lockdown,
I think,
was the last time we talked.
-Mm-hmm.
-And you and Justin
have been married for two years,
two and a half years?
Which technically means
that you've spent
half of your marriage so far
in quarantine.
-Yeah, and that's exactly --
that's exactly what it is.
-According to social media,
what I saw,
it looks like there's
a lot of gaming going on.
-There's a lot
of gaming going on.
-What's your jam,
as far as games go,
and does it get competitive?
-Justin's a very competitive
person just in general.
I mean, I guess
I'm pretty competitive, too.
But the biggest thing
that was going on in our house
was a lot of "UNO,"
a lot of "Bananagrams."
I would like to say I think
that I'm the "UNO" champion,
but that's like self-proclaimed,
so whatever.
-Wow!
-But, yeah, lots of "UNO."
-I love "UNO," too.
-Lots of "Bananagrams."
I love that game.
I don't know if you know
what that is.
-Is that where
you put the titles
and you spell the words,
and it's a race almost?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I love that game.
I love "Bananagrams."
-Same.
It's my absolute favorite.
-And it's in a little zipper,
in a banana, and like
a little zipper thing?
-Uh-huh. They also have one,
too, called "Word-A-Melon"
that's really fun.
-Oh, I don't know that one.
-From the same people.
-Really?
-Yeah. You got to get into
"Word-A-Melon."
-I would tot-- "Word-A-Melon."
That's the best name for it.
Are you kidding me?
Oh, I love that.
-Yeah. It's so fun.
-I also heard that he was --
you guys were playing chess.
-Yeah. So, Justin's
really good at chess,
and he has played chess
since he was a kid,
and he was trying to --
This is also pre
"Queen's Gambit," by the way.
He was trying to teach me
how to play chess,
and he would win every time.
So far, I haven't gotten
to beat him yet,
because I was a new learner,
and I was just learning as I go.
So I think, honestly, low-key,
I think he just liked it
because he knew he was going
to win every time.
-He's like, "Let's do one more
practice thing,"
and he just loves winning.
I follow you on Instagram
and all the socials,
but you've been doing
a very cool thing.
You've been handing
over your Instagram
and having like social activists
and organizations take it over.
What made you decide to do that?
I think it's great.
-My point behind it was,
I wanted to reach out
to different people,
and if they were interested,
then just hand
over the Instagram
and let them talk about whatever
they were passionate about.
And I wanted it to be
an educational thing,
not only for the people
who follow me,
but I wanted to learn
along with them.
And I have been so inspired
and learned so much
from these incredible people.
And it's something
that I'm going to
definitely continue doing.
-I want to talk about
some other exciting news.
Today was a huge day for you,
because you officially launched
a YouTube channel.
I can't believe
that you did this.
Is this because of
the docu thing that you did,
the docuseries?
-I have to say,
when "Seasons" was coming out,
I was really nervous about it
because I felt like
I had never allowed anybody
into my world in that way.
And I'm -- you know,
I'm very protective of my space
and protective of my family
and the people that I love
and I care about.
So it was something
that was a little bit
on the more
uncomfortable side for me.
And then, what ended up
happening for me with "Seasons"
is, after the whole thing
came out,
the feedback that I got
from people,
not only
just friends and family
but just random people
would come up to me and be like,
"Hey, I saw you on 'Seasons,'
and, you know, I was really --
I was really surprised,"
or, "I really enjoyed it,"
and, "It was so nice to hear
from you in that way."
So it actually gave me
a confidence
and put me more in a space
of feeling like I was ready
to open myself up
as Hailey more to people.
And another part of why
I wanted to do this is,
they can't twist
what I'm trying to say,
you know, from YouTube.
It's coming straight
from my mouth.
And I think that's something
that I battled with a lot
is people trying to twist
my words or the media
taking something that I've said
or creating their own narratives
where if I control it,
that means that nobody can try
to turn it into something else.
You're hearing it
straight from me.
I can clear up
whatever I want to,
and that gives me
a lot of freedom, in a way.
-What kind of videos
are you gonna be making?
-We're gonna do a bunch
of different things.
We started a show on there
called "Who's in My Bathroom?"
which is very funny,
where I'm going to have
different guests come on,
and we're going to sit down
and we're gonna chat,
and we're gonna do weird,
quirky things in the bathroom.
So the first episode that aired
today is with Kendall Jenner,
who is one of my best friends.
-Oh, yeah.
-And we made macaroni and cheese
in the bathroom,
and we played
"Never Have I Ever"
and drank tequila.
-Come on.
I mean, come on, sold.
I'm in.
I'm watching. I can't wait.
-It's very fun.
It's lighthearted.
And we also --
we also are gonna do things
where we have conversations
with different people
about things
that I'm passionate about.
So we have a conversation
with a psychiatrist
named Dr. Jessica Clemons
where we talk about social media
and mental health.
So I wanted it to have a range
of different things
that just have to do with me
and that are important to me
and that are fun for me,
that are part of my life,
and just let people in
a little bit more.
-I love it.
You brought us a clip
from one of the videos.
Here is Hailey Bieber
and Kendall Jenner
playing a round of
"Never Have I Ever."
Take a look.
-Hoo! Okay, next question.
-Cheers.
I can say...
-Oh, yeah, wait, no, no.
If we haven't --
[ Laughter ]
-Breaking news?!
I'm all, "Cheers [bleep]"
♪♪
I'm sorry. Okay.
Let's take that again.
-We need to --
[ Laughter ]
-We got confused.
We've never been pregnant.
Nothing of that sort.
-Hailey Bieber,
it's always good to see you.
Check out her new
YouTube channel,
which is officially up
right now.